mr. chief justice senators in response
to that question
there are really two layers to my answer
because I'd like to point out first that
even if there was only one motive the
theory of abuse of power that the house
managers have presented that subjective
motive alone can become the basis for an
impeachable offense we believe is
constitutionally defective it is not a
permissible way to frame a claim of an
impeachable offense under the
Constitution so but I'll put that to one
side and address the question of mixed
motive if there were a motive that was
all the public interest but also some
personal interest we think it follows
even more clearly that that cannot
possibly be the basis for an impeachable
offense and even the house managers if
they have framed their case they have
explained and this is pointed out in our
trial memorandum that in the House
Judiciary Committee report they specify
that the standard they have to meet is
to show that this is a sham
investigation it's a bogus investigation
these investigations have there's not
any legitimate public purpose that's the
language any legitimate public purpose
that's the standard they've set for
themselves in being able to make this
claim under their theory of what an
abuse of power offense can be so it's a
very demanding standard that they've set
for themselves to meet and they've even
said they came up and they talked a lot
about the Biden's
they talked a lot about these issues in
twenty sixteen election interference
because they were saying there's not
even a scintilla a scintilla of any
evidence of anything worth looking into
there and that's the standard that they
would have to meet it's showing that
there's no possible public interest and
the president couldn't have had any
smidgen even of a public interest motive
because they recognize that once you get
into a mixed motive situation if there's
both some personal motive but also a
legitimate public interest motive
can't possibly be an offense because it
would be absurd to have the Senate
trying to consider well was it 48
percent legitimate interest and 52
percent personal inch or was it the
other way was at 53 percent and 46 you
can't divide it that way and that's why
they recognize that to have even a
remotely coherent theory the standard
they have to set for themselves is
establishing there is no possible public
interest at all for these investigations
and if there is any possibility if there
is something that shows a possible
public interest and the president could
have that possible public interest
motive that destroys their case so once
you're into mixed motive land it's clear
that their case fails there can't
possibly be an impeachable offense at
all and think about it all elected
officials to some extent have in mind
how their conduct how their decisions
their policy decisions will affect the
next election there's always some
personal interest in the electoral
outcome of policy decisions and there's
nothing wrong with that
that's part of representative democracy
and to go start saying now that well if
you've got a part motive that's for your
personal electoral gain that that's
somehow going to become an offense it
doesn't make any sense and it's totally
unworkable and it can't be a basis for
removing a president from office so the
bottom line is once you're into any
mixed motive situation once it is
established that there is a legitimate
public interest that that could justify
looking into something just asking a
question about something the manager's
case fails and it fails under their own
terms they recognize that they have to
show no possible public interest there
isn't any legitimate public interest and
they've totally failed to make that case
I think we've shown very clearly that
both of the things that were mentioned
2016 election interference and the Biden
verismo situation are things that raise
at least some public interest there's
something worth looking at there it's
never been investigated in the Biden
situation lots of their own witnesses
from the State Department said that on
its face it appears to be a conflict of
interest it's at least worth raising a
question about asking a question about
it and there is that public interest and
that means their case absolutely fails
thank you
Thank You counsel the Democratic leader
is recognized the Democratic leader asks
jaw of the house managers John are
Bolton's forthcoming book states that
the president wanted to continue
withholding 391 million dollars in
military aid to Ukraine until Ukraine
announced investigations into his top
political rival and the debunked
conspiracy theory about the 2016
election is there any way for the Senate
to render a fully inform verdict in this
case without hearing the testimony of
Bolton Mulvaney and the other key
eyewitnesses or without seeing the
relevant documentary evidence
Thank You mr. chief justice
the short answer that question is no
there's no way to have a fair trial
without witnesses and when you have a
witness who is as plainly relevant as
John Bolton who goes to the heart of the
most serious and egregious of the
president's misconduct who has
volunteered to come and testify to turn
him away to look the other way I think
as deeply at odds with being an
impartial juror I would also add in in
response to the last question that if
any part of the president's motivation
was a corrupt motive if it was a causal
factor in the action to freeze the aide
or withhold the meeting that is enough
to convict it would be enough to convict
under criminal law but here there's no
question about the president's
motivation and if you have any question
about the president's motivation it
makes it all the more essential to call
the man who spoke directly with the
president that the president confided in
and said he was holding up this aid
because he wanted Ukraine to conduct
these political investigations that
would help him in the next election if
you have any question about whether it
was a factor the factor a core of the
factor all of the factor there is a
witness a subpoena away who can answer
that question
but the overwhelming body of the
inspected very clear on July 26th the
day after that phone call Donald Trump
speaks to Gordon Sunland that's that
conversation that Ukraine restaurant and
what does Gordon Sandlin
what is the president's question of
Gordon Sunland the day after that call
is he going to do the investigations now
counsel the president would have you
believe the president was concerned
about burden-sharing well he may have
had a generic concern about
burden-sharing in other context but here
the motivation was abundantly clear on
that phone with Gordon silently the only
question he wanted an answer to was is
he gonna do the investigation now bear
in mind he's talking to the Ambassador
to the European Union what better person
to talk to if his real concern was about
burden-sharing than the guy responsible
for Europe's burden-sharing
but did the president raise this at all
of course not of course not and if you
have any question about it at all you
need to hear from his former national
security advisor don't wait for the book
don't wait to March 17th when it is in
black and white to find out the answer
to your question was it all the motive
some of the votive or none of the motive
now we think as I mentioned the case is
overwhelming it clear without John
Bolton but if you have any question
about it
you can erase all doubt now let me let
me show you a video underscore number
two slide two how important this is this
house managers really their goal should
be to give you all of the facts because
they're asking you to do something very
very consequential and ask yourself ask
yourself given the facts you've heard
today that they didn't tell you who
doesn't want to talk about the facts who
doesn't want to talk about the facts
impeachment shouldn't be a shell game
they should give you the facts last
video which is even more important and
OnPoint for mr. Bolten number three and
once again not a single witness in the
house record that they compiled and
developed under their procedures that
we've discussed and will continue to
discuss provided any first-hand evidence
that the president ever linked the
presidential meeting to any
investigations anyone who spoke with the
president said that the president made
clear that there was no linkage between
security assistance and investigations
oh that's not correct
right because of course Mick Mulvaney
said that the money was linked to these
investigations he said in acknowledging
a quid pro quo they do it all the time
and we should just get over it Gordon
Sandlin also said the president said on
the one hand no quid pro quo but also
made it clear that szalinski had to go
to the mic and announce these
investigations thank you Thank You
justice mr. Chief Justice in Turkey I
have a question for the President's
Council
to the President's Council would you
please respond to the arguments or
assertions the house managers just made
in response to the previous question mr.
chief justice senators a couple of
points that I'd like to make manager
Schiff
suggested that there was no evidence the
president was actually interested in
burden-sharing because he didn't
apparently according to David Hale raise
it in the telephone conversation that he
had with Gordon Sandlin that Hale claims
to have overheard at a restaurant in
Kiev but let's look at the real evidence
as we explained on June 24th there is an
email in the record showing it's an
email from one person at the Department
of Defense to another with a subject
line of POTUS follow-up president the
United States follow-up asking
specifically about burden-sharing
it says quote what do other NATO members
spend to support Ukraine end quote
that was what they were following up on
for the president and in the transcript
itself excuse me in the Tran the
transcript of the July 25th call itself
the president asked he said we spend a
lot of effort and a lot of time for
Ukraine much more than the European
countries are doing and they should be
helping you more than we are
Germany does almost nothing for you all
they do is talk and I think it's
something you should really ask them
about and he goes on to say that he
talks to Angela Merkel about it and that
they're not really doing as much as the
United States is doing he's raising
burden sharing and president szalinski
agreed with him now managership also
suggested that there is evidence of some
connection between the military
assistance and
investigations into 2016 election
interference because of a statement that
acting chief of staff Mulvaney made at a
press conference but that has been it's
been clear in the record since that
press conference that what he was saying
was garbled and/or misunderstood and he
immediately clarified and said on that
day quote the president never told me to
withhold any money until the Ukrainians
did anything related to the server and
quote and similarly he issued a
statement just the other day making
clear again that he said this is from
his counsel so it's raised in the third
person mr. Moghe nor did mr. Mulvaney
ever have a conversation with the
president or anyone else indicating that
Ukrainian military aid was withheld in
exchange for Ukrainian investigation of
Purisima abidance or the 2016 election
that is mr. Mulvaney statement lastly on
to the point of whether this chamber
should hear from ambassador Bolton and I
think it's important to consider what
that means because it's not just a
question of well should we just hear one
witness that's not what the real
question is going to be for this
institution the real question is what is
the precedent that is going to be set
for what is an acceptable way for the
House of Representatives to bring an
impeachment of a president of the United
States to this chamber and can it be
done in a hurried half-baked partisan
fashion without they didn't even
subpoena John Bolton below they didn't
even try to get his testimony and to
insist now that this body will become
the investigate investigative body that
this body will have to do all the
discovery and that this institution will
be effectively paralyzed for months on
end because it has to sit as a court of
impeachment while now discovery is done
because it would be ambassador Bolton
and if they're going to be witnesses
then the president would have to in
order they said fair trial fair
adjudication then the president would
have to have his opportunity to call his
witnesses and there'd be depositions and
this would drag on for months and that's
the new precedent
then that's the way all impeachments
operate in the future the house doesn't
have to do the work they do it quick
they throw it over the transom and this
institution gets derailed and has to
deal with it and that should not be the
way that should not be the precedent
that is set here for the way this body
will have to handle all impeachments in
the future because if it becomes that
easy for the house to do it they'll be
doing it a lot thank you the senator
from Massachusetts send a question to
the desk question from Senator Markey to
the house managers on Monday president
Trump tweeted the democrat-controlled
house never even asked john bolton to
testify end quote so that the record is
accurate did house impeachment
investigators ask mr. Bolton to testify
senators the answer is yes of course we
asked John Bolton to testify in the
house and he refused we asked his deputy
dr. Kupperman to testify and he refused
fortunately we asked their deputy dr.
Fiona Hill to testify and she did we
asked her deputy the Colonel Amendment
to testify and he did but we did seek
the testimony of John Bolton as well as
dr. Kupperman and they refused when we
subpoenaed dr. Kupperman
he sued us took us to court when we
raised a subpoena with John Bolton's
counsel the same counsel for dr. Koopman
the answer was senator you serve us with
a subpoena and we will sue you too we
knew based on the McGann litigation it
would take months if not years to force
john bolton to come and testify and I
should point out because I think this is
an essential point to underscore as the
president's lawyers say they didn't try
hard enough to get John Bolton or they
should a subpoena John Bolton that's
what they're telling you but let me show
you what they're telling the court in
the McGann litigation if we could pull
up slide number 39 this is the
president's lawyers in court in the
McGann litigation in the court of
appeals right now quote the committee
meaning our committee lacks article 3
standing to sue to enforce a
congressional subpoena demanding
testimony from an individual on matters
related to duties as an executive branch
official I mean it takes your breath
away the duplicity of that argument
there before you saying they should have
tried harder to get these witnesses they
should subpoena they should have
litigated for years and down the street
in the federal courthouse they're
arguing judge you need to throw them out
they have no standing to sue to force a
witness to testify are we really
prepared to accept that now counsel says
think about the precedent that we would
be set
if you allow a house to impeach a
president and you permit them to call
witnesses well I would submit think
about the precedent you will be setting
if you don't allow witnesses in a trial
that to me is the much more dangerous
precedent here but I'll tell you there's
something even more dangerous and this
was something that we anticipated from
the very beginning which is we
understood when we got to this point
they could no longer contest the facts
that the present withheld military aid
from the ally at war to coerce that ally
to doing the president's political dirty
work so now they have fallen back on you
shouldn't hear any further evidence any
further witnesses on this subject what's
more we're gonna use the the end all
argument so what a president is free to
abuse their power we're going to rely on
a constitutional theory of fringe theory
that even the advocate of which says is
outside of the consensus of
constitutional law to say that a
president can abuse his power with
impunity imagine where that leads a
president can abuse his power with
impunity now that argument made by
professor Dershowitz is at odds with the
Attorney General's own expressed opinion
on the subject with pen stars expressed
opinion on the subject with not only
other counsel for the president Jonathan
Turley who testified in the house says
that theory is constitutional
effectively nonsense but even 60 old
year old Alan Dershowitz doesn't agree
with 81 year old Alan Dershowitz and for
a reason because where that conclusion
leads us is that a president can abuse
his power in any kind of way and there's
nothing you can do about it now are we
really ready to accept the position that
this president or the next can withhold
hundreds of millions of dollars in
military aid
to an ally at war unless they get help
in their reelection would we say that
you could as present withhold disaster
relief from a governor unless that
governor got his Attorney General to
investigate the president's political
rifle that to me is the most dangerous
argument of all it's a danger to have a
president who engage in this conduct
it's a danger to have a trial with no
witnesses and set that precedent but the
biggest danger of all I think would be
to accept the idea that a president can
abuse his office in this way and the
Congress is powerless to do anything
about it that is certainly not what the
founders intended mr. chief justice
senator from Tennessee Thank You mr.
chief justice
I send a question to the desk on my
behalf and also joined by senators
Lafleur Lee Kramer and mcsalley
the senators asked of counsel for the
president is the standard for
impeachment in the house a lower
threshold to meet than the standard for
conviction in the Senate and have the
house managers met their evidentiary
burden to support a vote of removal
mr. chief justice senators the standard
in the house of course the house is not
making a final determination in the
structure of the Constitution an
impeachment is simply an accusation and
as in most systems where there is simply
an accusation being made the house does
not have to adhere to the same standard
that is used in the Senate in most
instances House members have suggested
in debates on articles of whether or not
to approve articles of impeachment that
they should be have clear and convincing
evidence in the view of the members
voting on it that there was some
impeachable offense and that is all some
not even that standard and so it is
simply enough evidence that there an
accusation can be made it is definitely
a lower standard than a standard that
has to be met here on a trial for an
ultimate verdict the Constitution speaks
in terms of a conviction in the Senate
and as both professor Dershowitz and
Judge Starr pointed out in their
comments everywhere in the Constitution
that there is any mention of impeachment
it is spoken of in terms of the criminal
law the offenses that define the
jurisdiction for the Senate sitting as a
court of impeachment are treason bribery
and high crimes and misdemeanors the
Constitution speaks of a conviction upon
being convicted in the Senate
it speaks of all crimes being tried by
jury except in cases of impeachment
against again
notions of the criminal law and as we
pointed out in our trial memorandum all
of these textual references make it
clear that the standards of the criminal
law should apply in the trials certainly
to the extent of the burden and standard
of proof to be carried by the house
managers which means proof beyond a
reasonable doubt and is very clear that
there is not any requirement for proof
beyond a reasonable doubt simply for the
house to vote upon articles of
impeachment there's a very much higher
standard at stake
as we pointed out in our trial
memorandum the mere accusation made by
the house comes here with no presumption
of regularity at all in its favor the
Senate sits as trier of both fact and
law reviewing both factual and legal
issues de novo and the trial man the
house managers are held to a standard of
proving proof beyond a reasonable doubt
of every element of what would be a
cognizable impeachable offense here they
have failed in their burden of proof
they have also failed on the law they
have not stated in the articles of
impeachment anything that on its face
amounts to an impeachable offense and on
the facts I think we have demonstrated
very clearly that they have not
presented facts that would amount to an
impeachable offense even under their own
theories they presented only part of the
facts and left out the key facts and mr.
purpura I think went through very
effectively showing that there are some
facts that don't change the transcript
of the July 25th call shows the
president doing nothing wrong President
szalinski said he never felt any
pressure his other advisers have said
their crania never felt any pressure
they didn't think there was any quid pro
quo they didn't even know that the
military assistance had been held up
until the political article at the end
of August the only two people with
statements on record who spoke to the
president who are sawn hland and Senator
Ron Johnson report that the president
said to them there was no quid pro quo
and the aid flowed without ever anything
ever being done related to
investigations that is what's in the
record that is what the house managers
have to rely on to make their case and
they have failed to prove their case
beyond a reasonable doubt failed even to
prove it by clear and convincing
evidence failed to prove it at all in my
opinion thank you Thank You counsel
miss senator from California is
recognized
Thank You mr. Chief Justice I send a
question to the house managers
senator Feinstein asks the house
managers the President's Council stated
that quote there is simply no evidence
anywhere that President Trump ever
linked security assistance to any
investigations end quote
is that true
Thank You mr. Chief Justice and thank
you senator for that question the
President's Council is not correct there
is in fact overwhelming evidence that
the president withheld the military aid
directly to get a personal political
benefit to help his individual political
campaign there's a few points that I'd
like to submit for your consideration
first look no further than the words of
the president's acting chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney who on October 17th 2019
during a national press conference
mentioned quote or he was asked about
the direct connection between the aid
and he said quote did he meaning
president Trump referring to he quote
also mentioned to me in passing the
corrupt the corruption related to the
DNC server absolutely no question about
it but that's it and that's why we held
up the money in quote he was repeating
the president's own explanation relate
directly to him second Gordon Sandlin
testified he spoke by phone with
President Trump on September 7th the
president denied there was a quote quid
pro quo but then outlined the very quid
pro quo that he wanted from Ukraine then
he told presidents onlin to quote go
that president szalinski should quote go
to the microphone and announce the
investigations he should want to do it
third the president's own advisers
including the vice president and
secretary Pompeo were also aware of the
direct connection in Warsaw Anza Warsaw
on September first ambassador silent old
vice president pence that he was
concerned the delay in security
assistance had become quote tied to the
issue of investigations the vice
president simply nodded tacitly
acknowledging the conditionality of the
aid fourth we heard from ambassador
Taylor who indirectly emails and text
said it was crazy to tie the security
assistance to the investigations five we
also know there's no other reason the
entire apparatus and structure of the
Defense Department the State Department
that should have been dealing with the
other legitimate
reasons you know the policy debate that
the president's council wants you to
believe that this was about they were
all kept in the dark in the supposed
interagency process that they made up
several months after the fact had ended
months before during the last
interagency meetings and I'll make one
final point again if you have any
lingering questions about direct
evidence any thoughts about anything we
just talked about anything I just
relayed or that we've talked about the
last week there is a way to shed
additional light on it you can subpoena
ambassador Bolton and ask him that
question directly Thank You mr. manager
senator Lee asks of counsel for the
president the house managers have argued
aggressively that the president's
actions contravened u.s. foreign policy
isn't it the president's place certainly
more than the place of career civil
servants to conduct foreign policy
Thank You mr. chief justice senators and
thank you for that question
it is definitely the president's place
to set u.s. foreign policy and the
Constitution makes this clear article 2
section 1 vests the entirety of the
executive authority in a president of
the United States and it's critically
important in our constitutional
structure that that authority is vested
solely in the president because the
president is elected by the people every
four years that's what gives the
president democratic legitimacy to have
the powers that he is given under the
Constitution our system is somewhat
unique in the very broad powers that are
assigned to the executive but it works
and it makes sense in a democratic
system precisely because he is directly
accountable to the people for the
policies that he sets those who are
staffers in the executive branch
bureaucracy are not elected by the
people they have no accountability and
they have no legitimacy or authority
that comes from an election by the
people and so it's critically important
to recognize the president sets foreign
policy of course within some constraints
there's rules for Congress in foreign
affairs to some extent statutes can be
passed funding provisions can be passed
that relate to it but the constant the
Supreme Court has recognized time and
again that the president is as the court
said in Curtis Wright the sole organ of
the nation in foreign affairs so he sets
foreign policy and if staffers disagree
with him that does not mean that the
president is doing something wrong and
this is a critical point because this is
one of the centerpieces of the abuse of
power theory that the house managers
would like this body to adopt and that
is that they are going to impeach the
president based solely on his subjective
motive the premise of their case is the
object of actions that were taken
perfectly permissible and within the
president's constitutional authority but
if his real reason if we get inside his
head and figure it out then we can
impeach him and the way that they have
tried to explain that they can prove
that the President had a bad motive is
they say well we compare what did the
president want to do with what the
interagency consensus was and I
mentioned this the other day they say
that the president defied and confounded
every agency in the executive branch
that's a constitutionally incoherent
statement the president cannot defy the
agencies within the executive branch
that are subordinate to him it is only
they who can defy the president's
determinations of policy and what so
what this all boils down to really is it
shows that this case is built on a
policy difference and a policy
difference where the president is the
one who gets to determine policy because
he's been elected by the people to do
that and were right now only a few
months away from another election where
the people can decide for themselves
whether they like what the president has
done with that authority or not and
that's the way disputes about policy
like that should be resolved it's not
legitimate to say that there's some
interagency consensus that disagrees
with the president and therefore we can
show he did something wrong and
therefore he could be impeached that's
an extraordinarily dangerous proposition
because it lacks any democratic
legitimacy whatsoever it's contrary to
the Constitution and it should be
rejected by this body the president is
the one who gets to set foreign policy
because that's the role assigned to him
in the Constitution and it was even
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh who had
complained about the July 25th call
himself ultimately agreed that it was
only a policy difference it was a policy
concern that he raised about the call
it's not enough to impeach a president
of the United States thank you Thank You
counsel
the senator from New Hampshire mr. Chief
Justice I send a question to the desk
senator shaheen asks the house managers
the President's Council has argued that
the alleged conduct set out in the
articles does not violate a criminal
statute and thus may not constitute
grounds for impeachment as high crimes
and misdemeanors does this reasoning
imply that if the president does not
violate a criminal statute he could not
be impeached for abuses of power such as
ordering tax audits of political
opponents suspending habeas corpus
rights indiscriminately investigating
political opponents or asking foreign
powers to investigate members of
Congress
mr. chief justice senators I appreciate
the question the simple answer is that a
president can be impeached without a
statutory crime being committed that was
the position and the question was
rejected in President Nixon's case and
rejected again in President Clinton's
case it should be rejected here in
president Trump's case the great
preponderance of legal authority
confirms that impeachable offenses of
legal authority confirms that it is not
defined in criminal conduct this
Authority includes nearly every legal
scholar to have studied the issue
multiple Supreme Court justices who
addressed it in public remarks and prior
impeachments in the house this
conclusion follows that
constitutionalist history text and
structure and reflects the absurdities
and practical difficulties that would
result where the impeachment power
confined to indictable crimes as slight
thirty-five shows first the plain text
of the Constitution does not require
that an offense be a crime in order for
it to be impeachable Alexander Hamilton
explained that impeachable offenses high
crimes and misdemeanors are different
defined fundamentally by the abuse or
violation of some public trust some
public trust they are political as they
relate chiefly to injuries done
immediately
to the society itself offenses against
the Constitution are different that
offenses against the Criminal Code some
crimes like jaywalking are not
impeachable and some forms of misconduct
often offend the concept both offend the
Constitution and the criminal law
impeachment and criminality must
therefore be assessed separately even
though the president's commission of
indictable crimes may further support a
case
seven Pietschmann and removal the
American experience with impeachment
confirms this a strong majority of
impeachment voted by the House since
1789 have included one or more
allegations that did not charge a
violation of criminal law although
President Nixon resigned before the
house could consider the articles and
the Pietschmann against him the
Judiciary Committee's allegations
encompass many many non criminal acts
and in President Clinton's case the
Judiciary Committee report accompanying
the articles of impeachment to the House
floor stated that quote the actions of
President Clinton do not have to rise to
the level of violating the federal
statute regarding articles obstruction
of justice in order to justify
impeachment their framers intended
impeachment to reach the full spectrum a
presidential misconduct that threaded
threatened the Constitution they also
intended that that our Constitution
endure throughout the ages in other
words if they named one two and three
but new ones came up if you had to keep
up at the times so it was better to have
the full spectrum of presidential
misconduct because they could not
anticipate and specifically prohibit
every single threat a president might
someday pose the framers adopted a
standard sufficiently general and
flexible to meet unknown future
circumstances this standard was meant
it's Mason put it to capture all manner
of great and dangerous offenses
incompatible with the Constitution when
the president uses the powers of his
high office to benefit himself while
injuring or ignoring the American people
his uni found to serve he has committed
an impeachable offense the records of
the Constitutional Convention offered
further clarity at the Constitutional
Convention itself no delegate
delegate link impeachment to the
technicalities of criminal law instead
the framers principally intended
impeachment for three forms of
presidential wrongdoing the ABCs of
impeachment a abuse of power B betrayal
of the national interest through foreign
entanglements and C corruption of office
and elections when a president abuses
his power to obtain illicit help in his
election from a foreign power and
undermine our national security and
election integrity
it is a trifecta thank you Thank You
counsel thank you the senator from
Louisiana
mr. Chief Justice along with Senator
Blackburn and Senator Cornyn I send a
question to the desk for the house
managers and for counsel for the
president in the case of such a question
addressed to both sides they will split
the five minutes equally
the senators asked why did the House of
Representatives not challenge president
Trump's claims of executive privilege
and/or immunity during the house
impeachment proceedings we'll begin with
the house managers
boksoon
mr. Chief Justice this thing with
senators thank you for your question
the answer is simple we did not
challenge any claims related to
executive privilege because as the
president's own counsel admitted during
this trial the president never raised
the question of executive privilege what
the President did raised was this notion
of blanket defiance this notion that the
executive branch directed by the
president could completely defy any and
all subpoenas issued by the House of
Representatives not turn over documents
not turn over witnesses not produce a
single shred of information in order to
allow us to present the truth to the
American people in the October 8th
letter that was sent to the House of
Representatives there was no
jurisprudence that was cited to justify
the notion of blanket defiance there has
been no case law cited to justify the
doctrine of absolute immunity in fact
every single court that has considered
any presidential claim of absolute
immunity such as the one asserted by the
White House has rejected it out of hand
president
mr. chief justice senators thank you for
that question let me frame this in
partly in response to what manager
Geoffrey said and I went through this
before the idea that there was blanket
defiance and no explanation and no case
law from the White House is simply
incorrect I put up slides showing the
letters a letter from October 18th that
explained specifically that the
subpoenas that had been issued by the
house because they were not authorized
from by a vote from the house were
invalid and there was a letter from the
White House Counsel saying that there
was a letter from OMB saying that there
was a letter from the State Department
saying that there were specific
rationales given citing the cases
Watkins room Lee and others explaining
that defect the house managers the house
managers ship chose not to take any
steps to correct that we also pointed
out other defects we asserted the
doctrine of absolute immunity for senior
advisors to the president which has been
asserted by every president since the
1970s they chose not to challenge that
in court we also explained the problem
that they didn't allow agency counsel to
be present at depositions they chose not
to challenge that in court these were
specific legal reasons not blanket
defiance right that's just a
misrepresentation of the record and
there was no attempt to have that
adjudicated in court and the reason that
there was no attempt is that the House
Democrats were just in a hurry they had
a timetable one of the house managers
said on the floor here they had no time
for courts they had to impeach the
president before the election so they
had to have that done by Christmas
that's why the proper process wasn't
followed here because it was a partisan
and political impeachment that they
wanted to get done all around timing for
the election thank you
Thank You counsel senator from Vermont
senator leahy asks the house managers
the President's Council argues that
there was no harm done that the aide was
ultimately released to Ukraine the
president met with szalinski at the UN
in September and that this president has
treated Ukraine more favorably than his
predecessors what is your response mr.
chief justice and Senator thank you so
much for her your question contrary to
what the white house counsel has said or
his claim that there was no harm no
filed that the aide eventually got there
we promise Ukraine in 2014 that if they
gave up their nuclear arsenal that we
would be there for them that we would
defend them that we would fight along
beside them 15,000 Ukrainians have died
it was interesting the other day when
the White House Council said that no
American life was lost and we are always
grateful and thankful for that but what
about our friends what about our allies
in Ukraine according to diplomat homes
and ambassador Taylor that our Ukrainian
friends continue to die on the front
lines those who were fighting for us
fighting Russian aggression when you
fight Russian aggression when the
Ukrainians have the ability to defend
themselves they have the ability to
defend us the aid although it did arrive
it took the work of some senators in
this room who had to pass additional
laws to make sure that the Ukrainians
did
lose out on 35 million additional
dollars and contrary to the president's
tweet that all of the aid arrived and
that it arrived ahead of schedule that
is not true
all of the aid has not arrived and let's
talk about what kind of signal
withholding the aid for no legitimate
reason the president talked about
burden-sharing
but nothing had changed on the ground
holding the aid for no legitimate reason
sent a strong message that we would not
want to send to russia that the
relationship between the United States
and Ukraine was on shaky ground
it actually undercut Ukraine's ability
to negotiate with Russia with whom as
everybody in this room knows is in an
active war in a hot war so when we talk
about the aid eventually got there no
harm no foul that is not true senators
and I know that you know that there was
harm and there was foul and let us not
forget that Ukraine is not an enemy
they're not an adversary they are
friends senator Cruz mr. Chief Justice I
send a question to the desk
the question is addressed to
for the president as a matter of law
does it matter if there was a quid pro
quo is it true that quid pro quos are
often used in foreign policy
thank you very much for your question
yesterday I had the privilege of
attending the rolling out of a peace
plan by the President of the United
States regarding the israel-palestine
conflict and I offered you a
hypothetical the other day what if the
Democratic president were to be elected
and Congress were to authorize much
money to either Israel or the
Palestinians and the Democratic
president were to say to Israel no I'm
gonna withhold this money unless you
stop all settlement growth or to the
Palestinians
I will withhold the money Congress
authorized to you unless you stopped
paying terrorists and the president said
quid pro quo if you don't do it you
don't get the money if you do it you get
the money there's no one in this chamber
that would regard that as in any way
unlawful the only thing that would make
a quid pro quo unlawful is if the quo
were in some way illegal now we talked
about motive there are three possible
motives that a political figure can have
one a motive in the public interest and
the Israel argument would be in the
public interest the second is in his own
political interest and the third which
hasn't been mentioned would be in his
own financial interest his own pure
financial interest just putting money in
them in the bank I want to focus on the
second one for just one moment every
public official that I know believes
that his election is in the public
interest and mostly you're right your
election is in the public interest and
if a president does something which he
believes will help him get elected in
the public interest that cannot be the
kind of quid pro quo that results in
impeachment I quoted President Lincoln
when President Lincoln told General
Sherman to let the troops go to Indiana
that they can vote for the Republican
Party let's assume the president was
running at that point and it was in his
electoral interest to have these
soldiers put at risk the lives of many
many other soldiers who would be left
without their company would that be an
unlawful quid pro quo no because the
president a believed it was in the
national interest but B he believed that
his own election was essential to
victory in the Civil War every president
believes that that's why it's so
dangerous to try to psychoanalyze a
president to try to get into the
intricacies of the human mind
everybody has mixed motives and for
there to be a constitutional impeachment
based on mixed motives would permit
almost any president to be impeached how
many presidents have made foreign policy
decisions after checking with their
political advisors and their pollsters
if you're just acting in the national
interest what do you need pollsters what
do you need political advisors just do
what's best to the country but if you
want to balance what's in the public
interest with what's in your party's
electoral interests in your own
electoral interest it's impossible to
discern how much weight is given to one
to the other now we may argue that it's
not in the national interest for a
particular president to get reelected or
for a particular senator or a member of
Congress and maybe you were right it's
not in the national interest for
everybody who's running to be elected
but for it to be impeachable you would
have to discern that he or she made a
decision solely on the basis of as the
house managers but it corrupt motives
and it cannot be corrupt motive if you
have a mixed motive that partially
involves the national interest partially
involves electoral and does not involve
personal pecuniary interests and the
house managers do not allege that this
decision this quid pro quo as they call
it and the question is based on the
hypothesis there was a quid pro quo I'm
not
acting the facts they never allege that
it was based on pure financial reasons
it would be a much harder case if a
hypothetical President of the United
States said to a hypothetical leader of
a foreign country unless you build a
hotel with my name on it and unless you
give me a million dollar kickback I
would hold the funds that's an easy case
that's purely corrupt and in the purely
private interest but a complex middle
case is I want to be elected I think I'm
a great president I think I'm the
greatest president there ever was and if
I'm not elected the national interest
will suffer greatly that cannot be an
impeachable offense thank you Chief
Justice recognized the Democratic leader
mr. Chief Justice I send a question to
the desk the question is before the
house managers would you please respond
to the answer that was just given by the
president's counsel I would be delighted
there are two arguments that professor
Dershowitz makes one that is I have to
say a very odd argument for a criminal
defense lawyer to make and that is it is
highly unusual to have a discussion and
trial about the defendants state of mind
intent or mens rheya in every courtroom
in America in every criminal case or
almost every criminal case except for a
very small sliver there are strict
liability the question of the defendants
intent and state of mind is always an
issue so this is nothing novel here you
don't require a mind-reader in every
criminal case and I would assume in
every impeachment case yes you have to
show that the president was operating
from a corrupt motive and we have but he
also makes an argument that all quid pro
quos are the same and all are perfectly
copacetic now some of you said earlier
well
they could prove a quid pro quo over the
military now that would be something
well we have so now the argument shifts
to all quid pro quos are just fine
they're all the same well I'm gonna
apply professor Dershowitz own test he
talked about the step test John Rawls
the philosopher let's put the shoe on
the other foot and see how that changes
our perception of things but I want to
merge that argument with one of the
other presidential counsels argument
when they when they resorted to the what
about ISM about Barack Obama's open mic
now that was a very poor analogy I think
you'll agree but let's use that analogy
and let's make it more comparable to
today and see how you feel about this
scenario President Obama on an open mic
says to Medvedev hey Medvedev I know you
don't want me to send this military
money to Ukraine because they're
fighting and killing your people I want
you to do me a favor though I want you
to do an investigation of Mitt Romney
and I want you to announce you found
dirt on Mitt Romney and if you're
willing to do that quid pro quo I won't
give you crane the money they need to
fight you on the front line do any of us
have any question that Barack Obama
would be impeached for that kind of
misconduct are we really ready to say
that that would be okay if Barack Obama
asked Medvedev to investigate his
opponents and would withhold money from
an ally that it needed to defend itself
to get an investigation of Mitt Romney
that's that's the parallel here and to
say well yes we conditioned aide all the
time for legitimate reasons yes for
legitimate reasons you might say to a
governor of a state paid governor of a
state you should chip in more towards
your own disaster relief but if the
president's real motive in depriving a
state of disaster relief is because that
governor won't get his attorney general
to investigate the president's political
rival are we ready to say that the
president can sacrifice the interests of
the people of that state or
in the case of Medvedev the people of
our country because all quid pro quos
are fine it's carte blanche is that
really what we're prepared to say with
respect to this president its conduct or
the next because if we are then the next
person itis states can ask for an
erection an investigation of you they
can ask for help in their next election
from any foreign power and the art will
be made
nope Donald Trump was acquitted for
doing exactly the same thing therefore
it must not be impeaching bull now bear
in mind that efforts to cheat an
election are always going to be in
proximity to an election and if you say
you can't hold a president accountable
in an election year
where they're trying to cheat in that
election then you are giving them carte
blanche
so all quid pros are not the same
some are legitimate and some are corrupt
and you don't need to be a mind reader
to figure out which is which for one
thing you can ask john bolton thank you
mr. manager mr. chief justice
senator from Iowa I send a question to
the desk
you
senator Grassley asked counsel for the
president does the houses failure to
enforce its subpoenas render its quote
obstruction of Congress and quote theory
unprecedented mr. chief justice
senators the answer is yes as far as I
am aware there has never been a prior
instance in which there's been an
attempt even in the house as in the
Nixon proceeding nevermind in the
Clinton proceeding which actually left
the house and came to the Senate to
suggest that there can be obstruction of
Congress when there hasn't been anything
beyond simply issuing a subpoena getting
resistance and then throwing up your
hands and giving up and saying oh well
that's obstruction in the Clinton
situation most of the litigation was
with the Independent Counsel and their
approach is asserted and litigation and
litigation again and again but the point
is that the issues about the privileges
were all litigated and they were
resolved before things came to this body
similarly in the Nixon impeachment
proceeding in within the house a lot of
investigation had been done by the
Special Counsel and there was litigation
over assertions of privileges there in
order to get at the tapes and some tapes
or transcripts had already been turned
it over began there was litigation about
the assertion of the privilege in
response to the grand jury subpoena that
then fed into the houses proceedings so
it would be completely unprecedented for
the house to attempt to actually bring a
charge of obstruction into the Senate
where all they can present is well we
issued a subpoena and there were legal
grounds asserted for the invalidity of
the subpoena and there were different
grounds as I've gone through I won't
repeat them on detail here but some work
because the subpoenas were just invalid
when issued because there was no vote
some is that the subpoenas for witnesses
were invalid because seen
your advisors to the president had
absolute immunity from compulsion some
were that they were forcing executive
branch officials to testify without the
benefit of agency counsel and the
executive branch counsel with them so
the various reasons asserted for the
invalidity and the defects in various
subpoenas and then no attempt to enforce
them no attempt to litigate out what the
validity or invalidity might be but just
bring it here as an obstruction charge
is unprecedented and I'll note the house
managers have said and I'm sure that
they will say again today that well but
if we had gone to court the Trump
administration would have said that the
courts don't have jurisdiction over
those claims now that is that is true in
some cases there's one being litigated
right now related to the former counsel
to the president Don McGann the Trump
administration position just like the
position of the Obama administration is
that an effort by the house to enforce
the subpoena in article 3 court is a
non-justiciable
controversy that is our position and we
would argue that in court but that's
part of what would have to be litigated
that doesn't change the fact that the
house managers can't have it both ways
and want to make this clear the house
managers want to say that they have an
avenue for going to court they're using
that avenue for going to court they
actually told the court in Magan that
once they reached an impasse with the
executive branch the courts were the
only way to resolve the impasse and as I
explained the other day there are
mechanisms for dealing with these
disputes between the executive and
Congress the first is an accommodations
process they didn't do that we offered
to do that in the White House counsel's
October eighth letter they didn't do
accommodations if they think they can
sue they have to take that step because
the Constitution the courts have made
clear require incremental ISM in
disputes between the executive and the
legislative branch so if they think that
the courts can resolve that dispute
that's the next step they should do that
and have that litigated and then things
can proceed on to a higher level of
conference
but to jump straight to impeachment to
the ultimate constitutional
confrontation doesn't make sense it's
not the system that the Constitution
requires and it is unprecedented in this
case thank you the senator from Michigan
Thank You mr. chief justice I send a
question to the desk
Senator Stabenow asked the house
managers would the house managers care
to correct the record on any falsehoods
or mischaracterizations
in the White House's opening arguments
mr. Chief Justice and senators thank you
for that question we believe that the
president's team has claimed basically
there were six facts that have not been
met and will not change and all six of
those so-called facts are incorrect
let's be clear on July 25th that's not
the whole evidence before us even though
it includes devastating evidence of the
president's scheme president Trump's
intent was made clear on the July 25th
call but we had evidence of information
before the meetings with mr. Bolton the
text message to mr. solinsky's people
telling him he had to do the
investigations to get what he wanted all
of this evidence that makes us
understand that phone call even more
clearly now the president's team claimed
that mr. szalinski and other Ukrainians
said they never felt press pressure to
open investigations now of course they
didn't say that publicly they were
afraid of the Russians finding out but
Solinsky said privately that he didn't
want to be involved in US domestic
politics he resisted announcing the
investigations he only relented and
scheduled the CNN meeting adver became
clear that he was not going to receive
the the support that he needed and that
Congress had provided in our
appropriations that's the definition of
pressure now Ukraine the president's
lawyers say didn't know that Trump was
withholding the security assistance
until it was public many witnesses have
contested that including the open
statement by olenna Zirkle who was then
the Deputy Foreign Minister of Ukraine
that they knew about the president's
hold on the security matters and in the
end everyone knew was public
and after was Ukraine did relent and
schedule that testimony forth they said
no witnesses said security was
conditioned on the investigations not so
Mulvaney we had other witnesses talking
about the shakedown for the security
assistance but the important thing is
that you can get a witness who talked to
the president firsthand about what the
president thought he was doing
ultimately of course the funds or at
least some of them were released but the
White House meeting that the president
promised three different times still has
not occurred so and we still don't have
the investigation of the the Biden's
getting caught doesn't mitigate the
wrongdoing the president's unrepentant
and we fear he will do it again
now the Independent Government
Accountability Office concluded that the
president violated federal law when he
was held that aid that misconduct is
still going on all the aid has not yet
been released and finally I just like to
say there's been some confusion I think
I'm sure not intentional but the
president surely does not need the
permission of his staff about foreign
policy that information is offered to
you has evidence of what he thought he
was doing and he did not appear to be
pursuing a policy agenda he appeared
from all the evidence to be pursuing a
corruption a corruption of our election
that's upcoming a high crime and
misdemeanor that requires conviction and
removal I yield back
mr. Chief Justice a senator from
Arkansas I send a question to the desk
for the President's Council on behalf of
myself and senators Bozeman mcsalley
Blackburn Kennedy and Timmy
the senators asked the president's
counsel did the house bother to seek
testimony or litigate executive
privilege issues during the month during
which it held up the impeachment
articles before sending them to the
Senate mr. chief justice senators know
they they house did not seek to litigate
any of the privilege issues during that
time in fact they they filed no lawsuits
arising from this impeachment inquiry to
seek to contest the basis that the Trump
administration gave for resisting the
subpoena is the basis for why those
subpoenas were invalid and when
litigation was filed by one of the
subpoena recipients that was dr. Charles
Kupperman the deputy national security
adviser he went to the court and sought
a declaratory judgment saying presidents
told me I shouldn't go I have a subpoena
from the house saying I should go
please courts tell me what are my
obligations and that was filed I believe
around October 25th it was towards the
end of October very shortly within a few
days the court had set an expedited
briefing schedule and scheduled a
hearing for December 10th that was
supposed to hear both preliminary
motions to dismiss but also the merits
issues so they were going to get a
decision after a hearing on December
10th that would go to the merits of the
issue the house managers withdrew the
subpoena the the house of
representatives decided they wanted to
mood out the case so they wouldn't get a
decision so no the the house has not
pursued litigation to get any of these
issues resolved its affirmatively
avoided getting any litigation and that
seems to be at least in part based on if
you look at the House Judiciary
Committee report their assertion that
under the sole power of impeachment a
sign
the house the house believes that the
Constitution assigns I believe the exact
words are it gives the house the last
word something to that effect and I
mentioned this the other day this is the
new constitutional theory that because
they have the sole power of impeachment
in their view it's actually the
paramount power of impeachment and all
other constitutionally based privileges
or rights or immunities or roles even of
the other branches both the judiciary
and the executive fall away and there is
nothing that can stand in the way of the
houses power of impeachment if they
issue a subpoena the executive has to
respond and it can't raise any
constitutionally based separation of
powers concerns if you do that's
obstruction the courts courts have no
role the house has the sole power of
impeachment that's a very dangerous
construct for our Constitution it
suggests that once they flip the switch
on to impeachment there's no check on
their power on what they want to do and
that's not the way the Constitution is
structured the Constitution requires
when there are inter branch conflicts
that there be an accommodation process
that there be attempts to address the
interests of both branches and that the
house has taken the position and in
other litigation the McGann litigation
they're telling the courts the courts
are the only way to resolve these issues
and they've brought that case in August
they already have a decision from the
district court they have an appeal in
the DC Circuit it was argued on January
3rd a decision could come any day that's
pretty fast for litigation but they've
decided in this impeachment they don't
they don't want to do litigation and
again it's because they had a timetable
one of the house managers admitted on
this floor they had to get the president
impeached before the election they had
no time for the courts for anyone
telling them what the rules were and
they had to get it done by Christmas and
that's what they did and then they
waited around for the month before
bringing it here and I think that shows
you what's really behind the claims of
oh it's urgent then it's not
Virgen it was urgent when it's our
timetable to get done by Christmas it's
not so urgent when we can wait for a
month because we want to tell the Senate
how to run things it's all a political
charade and that's part of the reason a
major reason that the Senate should
reject these articles of impeachment
thank you
Thank You counsel Costas the senator
from New Mexico thank you for the
recognition mr. Chief Justice I send a
question to the desk
the question is for the house managers
please address the president's counsels
argument that house managers seek to
overturn the results of the 2016
election and that the decision to remove
the president should be left to the
voters in November
thank you for the question and you know
first I just want to respond to
something counsel just said nine months
is pretty fast for litigation in the
courts sadly I agree with that nine
months is pretty fast in the Magan case
and we still don't have a decision yet
and what's more that's the very case in
which they're arguing as I quoted
earlier that Congress has no right to
come to the courts to force a witness to
testify so here we are nine months later
in that litigation that they said we're
compelled in the Constitution to bring
and they're saying in court you can't
bring this and it's nine months and we
still don't have a decision I think that
tells you just where they're coming from
it all goes back to the president's
directive fight all subpoenas and they
are Nixon was going to be impeached for
far less obstruction than anything that
Donald Trump did now the argument well
if you impeach a president you are
overturning the results of the last
election and you're tearing up the
ballots in the next election okay if
that were the case there would be no
impeachment clause in the Constitution
because by definition if you're
impeaching a president that president is
in office has won an election clearly
that's not what the founders had in mind
what they had in mind is if the
president commits high crimes and
misdemeanors you must remove him from
office
it is not voiding the last election it
is protecting the next election indeed
the impeachment power was put in the
Constitution not as a punishment that's
what the criminal laws are for but to
protect the country now if you say you
can't impeach a president before the
next election what you're really saying
is you can only impeach a president in
their second term okay if that were
going to be the constitutional
requirement the founders would have put
in the Constitution a president may
commit whatever high crimes and
misdemeanors that he wants as long as
it's in the first term that is clearly
not what any rational framer would have
written indeed they didn't and they
didn't for a reason the founders were
concerned that in fact the object of a
president's corrupt scheme might be to
cheat in the very form of accountability
that they had described the election so
counsel has continued to mischaracterize
what the managers have said
we're not saying that we had to hurry to
impeach the president before the
election we had to hurry because the
president was trying to cheat in that
election and the position of the
president's counsel is well yes it's
true that if a president is going to try
to cheat an election by definition
that's prior to their re-election by
definition that's going to be proximate
to an election but you know let the
voters decide even though the object is
to corrupt that vote of the people that
cannot be what the founders had in mind
one of the things I said at the very
open of this proceeding is yes we're to
look to history
yes we're to try to divine the intent of
the framers but we are not to leave our
common sense at the door the issue isn't
whether this is his first term or a
second it isn't whether the election is
a year away or three years away the
issue is did he commit a high crime and
misdemeanor is it a high crime and
misdemeanor for president nine states to
withhold hundreds of millions of dollars
in aid to an ally at war to get help
elicit foreign interference in our
election if you believe that it is it
doesn't matter what term it is doesn't
matter how far away the election is
because that president represents a
threat to the integrity of our elections
and more than that a threat to our
national security as we have shown by
withholding that aid and I know the
argument no harm no foul we withhold
held aid from an ally at war we sent a
message to the Russians when they
learned of this hold that we did not
have Ukraine's back we sent a message to
the Russians as szalinski was going into
negotiations with Putin to try to end
that war that Solinsky was operating
from a position of weakness because
there was a division between the
President of the United States and
Ukraine that's immediate damage that's
damage done every day that damage
continues to this day the damage the
president does in pushing out the
Russian conspiracy theories were
identified during the house proceedings
and you've heard in the Senate as
Russian intelligence propaganda the
danger the president poses by taking
Vladimir Putin side over his own
intelligence agencies that's a danger
today that's a danger that can that
continues every day he pushes out this
Russian propaganda the framers if they
meant impeachment only to imply in a
second term would have said so but that
would have made the Constitution a
suicide pact that's not what it says and
that's not how you should interpret it
the senator from Ohio thank you
the question is directed to Council for
the president given that impeachment
proceedings are privileged in the Senate
and largely prevent other work from
taking place while they are ongoing
please address the implications of
allowing the house to present an
incomplete case to the Senate and
request the Senate to seek testimony
from additional witnesses thank mr.
chief justice
senators I think this is one of the most
important issues that this body faces
given these calls to have witnesses
because the house managers try to
present it as if it's just a simple
question how can you have a trial
without witnesses but in real litigation
no one goes to trial without doing
discovery no one goes to trial without
having heard from the witnesses first
you don't show up at trial and then
start trying to call witnesses for the
first time and the implications here in
our constitutional structure for trying
to run things in such an upside-down way
would be very grave for this body as an
institution because as the Senators
question points out it largely prevents
this chamber from getting other business
done as long as there is a trial pending
and the idea that the house can do an
incomplete job in trying to find out
what witnesses there are having them
come testify trying to find out the
facts just rush something through and
bring it here as an impeachment and then
start trying to call all the witnesses
means that this body will end up taking
over that investigatory task and all of
the regular business of this body will
be slowed down hindered or prevented
while that goes on and it's not a
question of just one witness it's not a
question a lot of people talk right now
about john bolton but the president
have the opportunity to call his
witnesses just as a matter of
fundamental fairness and there would be
a long list of witnesses if the body
were to go in that direction that would
mean this would drag on for months and
prevent this chamber from getting its
business done there's there's a proper
way to do things in an upside-down way
of doing things and to have the house
not go through a process that is
thorough and complete and to just rush
things through in a partisan and
political matter and then dump it onto
this chamber to clean everything up is a
very dangerous precedent to be set as I
said the other day whatever is accepted
in this case becomes the new normal if
this chamber puts its imprimatur on this
process then that's the seal of approval
for all time in the future and if it
becomes that easy for the House of
Representatives to impeach a president
of the United States don't attempt to
subpoena the witnesses
never mind litigation it takes too long
but then leave it all to this chamber
and as I said the other day remember
what do we think will happen if some of
these witnesses are subpoenaed now that
they never bothered to litigate about
then there'll be the litigation now most
likely and then that will take time
while this chamber is still stuck
sitting as a court of impeachment that's
not the way to do things and it would
forever change the relationship between
the House of Representatives and the
Senate in terms of the way impeachments
operate so I think it's vitally
important for this chamber to consider
what it really means to start having
this chamber do all that investigatory
work how this chamber would be paralyzed
by that and is that really the precedent
is that the way this chamber wants
everything to operate in the future once
you make it that much easier and we've
said this on a couple of different
points both in terms of the standards
for impeachable offenses but also in
terms of the process that's used in the
house you make it really way too easy to
impeach
then this chamber is going to be dealing
with that all the time and as as
Minority Leader Schumer had pointed out
at the time of the Clinton impeachment
he was prophetic as the White House
Counsel pointed out the other day once
you start down the path of partisan
impeachments they'll be coming again and
again and again and if you make it
easier
they'll come even more frequently and
this chamber is gonna be have to
spending a lot of time dealing with
impeachment trials and cleaning up in
complete half baked procedures rushed
partisan impeachments from the house if
that's the sort of system that's given
your imprimatur here and that's a very
important reason for not accepting that
procedure and not trying to open things
up now when things haven't been done
properly in the House of Representatives
thank you so the senator from Delaware
so Chief Justice I send a question to
the desk
the question is for the house managers
some have claimed that subpoenaing
witnesses or documents would
unnecessarily prolong this trial isn't
it true that depositions of the three
witnesses in the Clinton trial were
completed in only one day each and isn't
it true that the Chief Justice as
providing officer in this trial had the
authority to resolve any claims of
privilege or other witness issues
without any delay
mr. Chief Justice the answer is yes
what is clear based on the record that
was compiled by the House of
Representatives we're up to five
depositions per week were completed that
this can be done in an expeditious
fashion it's important to note that the
record that exists before you right now
contains strong and uncontroverted
evidence that President Trump pressured
a foreign government to target an
American citizen for political and
personal gain as part of a scheme to
cheat in the 2020 election and solicit
foreign interference that is evidence
from witnesses who came forward from the
Trump administration including
individuals like ambassador Bill Taylor
West Point graduate Vietnam War hero
including individuals like ambassador
Sandlin
who gave 1 million dollars to president
Trump's inauguration respected national
security professionals like Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander bin Minh as well as
dr. Fiona Hill 17 different witnesses
Trump administration employees troubled
by the corrupt conduct that took place
as alleged and proven by the House of
Representatives but to the extent that
there are ambiguities in your mind this
is a trial a trial involves witnesses a
trial involves documents a trial
involves evidence that is not a new
phenomenon for this distinguished body
the Senate in its history has had 15
different impeachment
in every single trial there were
witnesses every single trial
why should this president be treated
differently held to a lower standard at
this moment of presidential
accountability and in fact in in many of
those trials there were witnesses who
testified in the Senate who had not
testified in the house that was the case
most recently in the Bill Clinton trial
it certainly was the case in the trial
of President Johnson 37 out of the 40
witnesses who testified in the Senate
were new 37 out of foot why can't we do
it in this instance when you have such
highly relevant witnesses like john
bolton who had a direct conversation
with President Trump indicating that
President Trump was withholding the aide
because he wanted the phony
investigations counsel has said the
greatest invention in the history of
jurisprudence for ascertaining the truth
has been the vehicle of
cross-examination
let's call John Bolton let's call Mick
Mulvaney
let's call other witnesses subject them
to cross-examination and present the
truth to the American people
mr. Chief Justice the senator from Texas
Chief Justice I send me questions of the
desk thank you
senator Cornyn asks counsel for the
president what are the consequences to
the presidency the president's
constitutional role as the head of the
executive branch and the advice the
president can expect from his senior
advisors if the Senate seeks to resolve
claims of executive privilege for
subpoenas in this impeachment trial
without any determination by an article
3 court Mr Chief Justice and Thank You
senator for the question the Supreme
Court has recognized that the
confidentiality of communications with
the president is essential
keeping that those communications cut
the confidential is essential for the
proper functioning of government and
Nixon versus United States the Court
explained that this privilege is
grounded in the separation of powers and
essential for the functioning of the
executive for this reason in order to
receive candid advice the president has
to be able to be sure that those who are
speaking with him have the confidence
that what they say is not going to be
revealed that their advice can remain
confidential if it's not confidential
they would temper what they're saying
they wouldn't be candid with the
president and they wouldn't be able the
president then would not be able to get
the best advice and is the same concern
that underpins the deliberative process
aspect of executive privilege even if
it's not a communication directly with
the president if it's the deliberative
process within the executive branch
people have to be able before coming up
with a decision to discuss alternatives
to probe what are their ways might work
to address a problem and to discuss them
candidly and openly not with the feeling
that the first thing they say is going
to be on the front page of The
Washington Post the next day because if
if you don't have the confidence that
what you're saying is going to be kept
confidential you won't be candid you
won't give your best advice
and that damages decision-making that's
bad for the government and it's bad for
the people of the United States because
it means the government in the executive
branch can't function efficiently so
there is a critical need for the
executive to be able to have these
privileges and to protect them and
that's why the Supreme Court recognized
that in Nixon versus United States and
pointed out that there has to be some
very high showing of need from another
branch of government if there's going to
be any breach of that privilege and
that's why there is an accommodations
process while the courts have said that
when the Congress when the legislature
seeks information from the executive
executive its confidentiality interests
both branches are under an obligation
should try to come to some accommodation
to address the interests of both
branches but it's not a situation of
simply the Congress is supreme and can
demand information from the executive
and the executive must present
everything and the courts have made that
clear because that would be damaging to
the functioning of government and so
here in this case there are vital
interests at stake and you know in one
of the potential witnesses that the
house managers have raised again and
again is john bolton which on bolton was
the national security adviser to the
president he has all of the nation's
secrets from the time that he was the
national security adviser and that's
precisely the area the field in which
the Supreme Court suggested in Nixon
versus United States there might be
something approaching an absolute
privilege of confidentiality in
communications with the President the
field of national security and foreign
affairs
that's the crown jewels of executive
privilege and so to suggest that the
national security adviser well we'll
just subpoena him he'll come in and
that'll be easy there won't be any
problem
that's not the way it would work because
there's a vital constitutional privilege
at stake there and it's important for
the institution of the office of the
presidency for every president to
protect that privilege
because once precedents start to be said
if one president says well I won't
insist on the privilege then I'll let
people interview this person I won't
insist on the immunity that sets
precedents and then the next time when
it's important to preserve the privilege
the precedent is raised and the
privilege has been weakened and it's
forever weekend and that damages the
functioning of government so this is a
very serious issue to consider it's
important the Supreme Court has made
clear for the proper functioning of the
executive branch for the proper
functioning of our government and there
would be grave issues raised attempting
to have a national security adviser that
president come under subpoena to testify
and that would all have to be dealt with
and that would take some time before
things would continue Thank You counsel
the senator from Hawaii mr. Chief
Justice I send a question to the desk
the question from Senator Schatz is
directed to the house managers Channel
also from senator Feinstein if the
president were acting in the interest of
national security as he alleges would
there be documentary evidence or
testimony to substantiate his claim if
yes has any evidence like that been
presented by the president's counsel
you Thank You mr. chief justice Thank
You senators for the question the answer
is yes right there are well established
processes mechanisms and agencies in
place to pursue valid and legitimate
national security interests of the
United States like the National Security
Council like the National Security
Adviser as in Ambassador John Bolton and
you many other folks within the State
Department and the Department of Defense
and as we have well established over the
last week
none of those folks none of those
agencies that would have been involved
and having that deliberation reviewing
that evidence having that discussion
were incorporated into any type of
interagency review process during the
vast majority of the time that we are
talking about here from the time of the
president's call on July 25th to the
time the lift the hold was lifted those
individuals those agencies were in the
dark they didn't know what was happening
and more so not only were they in the
dark
but the president violated the law by by
that violating the impoundment Control
Act to execute his scheme
none of that suggests a valid legitimate
policy objective more so the President
himself and his council is bringing at
issue the question of documents of
witnesses if over and over again as
we've heard in the last few days that
the president was simply pursuing a
valid legitimate policy objective if
this was a specific debate about policy
a debate about corruption a debate about
burden sharing then let's have the
documents that would show that let's
hear from the witnesses that would show
that because the documents and the
witnesses that we have forwarded that we
have talked about show the exact
opposite so the American people in this
chamber deserve to have a fair trial the
president deserves
to have a fair trial in fact if he is
arguing that there is evidence that
there was a policy debate then I think
everybody would love to see those
documents would love to see the
witnesses hear from them directly about
what exactly was being debated Thank You
mr. manager there's chief justice the
senator from South Carolina I sent a
question to the desk from our self and
senator Cruz thank you
Senator Graham and senator Cruz posed
this question for the house managers in
mr. shifts hypothetical if President
Obama had evidence that Mitt Romney's
son was being paid 1 million dollars per
year by a corrupt Russian company and
Mitt Romney had acted to benefit that
company would Obama have authority to
ask that that potential corruption be
investigated well first of all the
hypothetical is a bit off because it
presumes that in that hypothetical that
President Obama was acting corruptly or
there was evidence he was acting
corruptly with respect to his son but
nonetheless let's take your hypothetical
on its terms would it have been impeach
bullet Barack Obama had tried to get
Medvedev to do an investigation of Mitt
Romney whether it was justified or
unjustified the reality is for a
president to withhold military aid from
an ally or in the hypothetical to
withhold it to benefit an adversary to
target their political opponent is wrong
and corrupt period end of story and if
you allow a president to rationalize
that conduct rationalize jeopardizing
the nation's security to benefit himself
because he believes that his opponent
should be investigated by a foreign
power that is impeachable now if you
have a legitimate reason to think that
any US person has committed an offense
there are legitimate ways to have an
investigation conducted there are
legitimate ways to have the Justice
Department conduct investigation I would
suggest to you that for a president to
turn to his Justice Department and say I
want you to investigate my political
rival taints whatever investigation they
do president should not be in the
business of asking even their own
Justice Department
to investigate their rivals the Justice
Department ought to have some
independence from the political desires
of the president and one of the deeply
troubling circumstances of the current
presidency is you do have a president
nine states speaking quite openly urging
his Justice Department to investigate
his perceived enemies that should not
take place either but under no
circumstances do you go outside of your
own legitimate law enforcement process
to ask a foreign power to investigate
your arrival whether you think there's
cause or you don't think there's cause
and you certainly don't invite that
foreign power to try to influence an
election to your benefit it's remarkable
to me that we even have to have this
conversation in our own FBI director has
made it abundantly clear and it
shouldn't require an FBI director to say
this that if we were approached with an
offer of foreign help we should turn it
down we should of course certainly not
solicit a foreign country to intervene
in our election and whether we think
there's grounds or we don't the idea
that we would hold our own country's
security hostage by withholding aid to a
nation at war to either damage our ally
or help our adversary because they will
conduct an investigation into our
opponent I can't imagine any
circumstance where that's justified and
I can't imagine any circumstance where
we would want to say the president
United States can target his rival can
solicit elicit foreign help in an
election can help him cheat and that's
okay because that will dramatically
lower the bar for what we have a right
to expect in the president I States and
that is their acting in our interests so
I would say it's wrong for president
nine states to be asking for political
prosecutions by his own Justice
Department I would say it's wrong for
president
States to ask a foreign power to engage
an investigation of his political rival
but particularly where as we have shown
here there is no merit to that
investigation is even more egregious and
you know there's no merit to it because
he didn't even want the investigation
and the more accurate parallels senator
would be if if Barack Obama said I don't
even need you Russia to do the
investigation I just want you to
announce it because that betrays the
fact there was no legitimate basis
because the president didn't even need
the investigation done
he just wanted it announced and there is
no legitimate explanation for that
except he wanted their help in cheating
in the next election the senator from
Michigan Chief Justice I sent a question
to the desk thank you
the question from Senator Peters is for
the house managers does the phrase or
other high crimes and misdemeanors in
article 2 section 4 of the Constitution
require a violation of the u.s. Criminal
Code or is a breach of public trust
sufficient please explain
Hamer's were very clear that abuse of
power is an impeachable offense in
explaining why the Constitution must
allow impeachment Edmund Randolph warned
that quote the executive will have great
opportunities of abusing his power
Alexander Hamilton described high crimes
and misdemeanors as offenses which
proceeded from the abuse or violation of
some public trust the framers also
described what it meant
it was impeachable for a president to
abuse his pardon power to shelter people
he was connected with in a suspicious
manner future Supreme Court Justice
James E Radel said the president would
be liable to impeachment if he'd acted
from some corrupt motive or other or if
he was wilfully abusing his trust as was
later stated in a treatise summarizing
centuries of common law abuse of power
occurs if a public officer and trusted
with definite powers to be exercised for
the benefit of the community wickedly
abuses or fraudulently exceeds them so
when the framers said this that abuse of
power was an impeachable wasn't just an
empty meaningless state remember the
founders had been participating with
overthrowing the British government a
king who was not accountable they
incorporated the impeachment power into
the Constitution late actually in the
drafting of the Constitution they knew
that they were giving the president many
powers and they specified if he abused
them that those powers could be taken
away now the prior articles that the
Congress has had on impeachment did not
include specific crimes President Nixon
was charged with abusing his power
targeting political opponents engaging
in a government up now there was conduct
specified
some of it was clearly criminal some of
it was not but it was all impeachable
because it was corrupt and it was
abusing his power in the House Judiciary
Committee we had witnesses called by
both Republicans and Democrats and the
Republicans invited constitutional law
expert Jonathan Turley testified
unequivocally that it is possible to
establish a case for impeachment based
on a non criminal allegation of abuse of
power every presidential impeachment
including this one has included conduct
that violated the law but each
presidential impeachment has included
the charges directly under the
Constitution it's important to note that
a specific criminal law violation was
not in the minds of the founders and it
wouldn't make any sense today you could
have a criminal law violation
you could you could deface a post office
box that would be a violation of federal
law we would laugh at the idea that that
would be a basis for impeachment that is
not abuse of presidential powers it
might be a crime and yet you could have
activities that are so dangerous to our
Constitution that are not a crime that
would be charged as an impeachable
offense because they are an abuse of
power that's what the fate the framers
worried about that's why they put the
impeachment clause in the Constitution
and frankly they opine that because of
the impeachment clause no executive
would dare exceed their powers
regrettably that prediction did not
prove true which is why we are here
today with President Trump having abused
his broad powers to the detriment of our
national interest for a crop purpose his
own personal in
thank you Thank You counsel mr. chief
justice
Oh senator Thank You mr. Thank You mr.
Chief Justice I send a question to the
desk enemies on behalf of myself and
Senator Murkowski Thank You senator
senators asked counsel for the president
described in further detail your
contention that all subpoenas issued
prior to the passage of House Resolution
660
of invalid subpoena authority by the
house committees
mr. chief justice
Thank You senators for that question as
I explained the other day this
contention is based on a principle that
has been laid out in several Supreme
Court cases explaining that the
Constitution assigns powers to each
house of the legislative branch to the
House of Representatives or to the
Senate and in particular the language of
the Constitution is clear in article one
that the sole power of impeachment is
assigned to the house that's to the
House of Representatives as a body it's
not assigned to any committee to a
subcommittee or to any particular member
of the House and in cases such as Room
Lee versus United States and the United
States versus Watkins the court has been
called there are disputes about
subpoenas they're not specifically in
the impeachment context but they
establish a general rule a principle
that whenever a committee of either body
of Congress issues a subpoena to someone
and that person resists the subpoena the
courts will examine what was the
authority of that committee or
subcommittee to issue that subpoena and
it has to be traced back to some
authorizing rule or resolution from the
House of Representatives itself for
example in a House subcommittee and the
courts will examine the the Supreme
Court has made clear that that is the
Charter of the committee's authority it
gets its authority solely from an action
by the house itself that requires a vote
of the house either to establish the
committee by resolution or to establish
by rule the standing Authority of that
committee and if the committee cannot
trace its authority to a rule or a
resolution from the house then it's
subpoena is invalid and the Supreme
Court's made clear in those cases such
as subpoenas are null and void because
they're all true varies there beyond the
power of the committee to issue they
can't be enforced and our point here is
very simple there is no standing rule in
the house
that provides the committee's that were
issuing subpoenas here under the the
leadership of manager shift the
authority to use the impeachment power
to issue subpoenas rule 10 of the house
defines the legislative jurisdiction of
committees it doesn't mention the word
impeachment even once and so no
committee under rule 10 was given the
authority to issue subpoenas for
impeachment purposes and this has always
been the case in every presidential
impeachment in the history of the nation
there has always been a resolution from
the house first to authorize a committee
to use the power of impeachment before
it attempted to issue compulsory process
so in this case there was no resolution
from the house the authority the sole
power impeachment remained with the
House of Representatives itself and
speaker Pelosi by herself did not have
authority merely by talking to a group
of reporters on September 24th to give
the powers of the house to any
particular committee to start issuing
subpoenas
so the subpoenas that were issued were
invalid when they were issued and then
five weeks later on October 31st when
the house finally adopted House
Resolution 661 at point purported to
authorize at least from that point the
issuance of subpoenas nothing in that
resolution addressed the subpoenas that
had already been issued it didn't even
attempt it didn't purport to say the
ones that have already been issued we're
going to try to retroactively Lee give
authority for that it's a separate
question whether that could have been
done legally they didn't even attempt to
do it and this is all explained in the
opinion from the Office of Legal Counsel
which is in our trial memorandum
attached as Appendix C and it's a very
detailed and thorough opinion 37 pages
of legal reasoning but it explains all
of this the basic principle that applies
generally the history that has always
been done this way there is always in
every presidential impeachment been an
authorizing resolution from
the house and the fact that there was
none here so there was no Authority for
those subpoenas and that means that 23
subpoenas that were issued were invalid
and this was explained as I pointed out
the other day in letters from the
administration to the committee's letter
from the White House from OMB I think
the State Department and in very
specific terms that set out this
rationale so that is the basis on which
those subpoenas were invalid and they
were properly resisted by the
administration thank you
Thank You counsel the senator from
Pennsylvania mr. chief justice I send a
question to the desk thank you the
question is directed to the house
managers in Federalist 65 Alexander
Hamilton writes that the subjects of
impeachment are quote those offenses
which proceeded from the misconduct of
public men or in other words from the
abuse or violation of some public trust
end quote could you speak broadly to the
duties of being a public servant and how
you believe the president's actions have
violated this trust
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
President Trump used the powers of his
office to solicit a foreign nation to
interfere in our elections for his own
benefit
then he actively obstructed Congress in
his attempts to investigate his abuses
of power these actions are clearly
impeachable the key purpose of the
impeachment Clause is to control abuses
of power by public officials that is to
say conduct that violates the public
trust since the founding of the Republic
all impeachments have been based on
accusations of conduct that violates the
public trust when the framers wrote the
phrase high crimes and misdemeanors they
intended to capture the conduct of
public officials like President Trump
who showed no respect for their oath of
office President Trump ignored the law
and the Constitution in order to gain a
political favor the Constitution and his
oath of office prohibited him from using
his official favor to corruptly benefit
himself rather than the American people
that's exactly what the President did
illegally withholding military aid and a
White House meeting until the president
of Ukraine committed to announcing an
investigation of president Trump's
opponent in the words of one
constitutional scholar if what we're
talking about is not impeachable then
nothing is impeachable this is precisely
the misconduct that the framers created
the Constitution including impeachment
to protect against and now I want to add
and we have reference to some of the
comments that were made by some of the
president's counsel a few minutes ago
they talked about the subpoena power
about the failure that house to act
properly in the subpoena power because
they said the house did not delegate by
rule delegate have a resolution
authorizing the committee's to offer
subpoena power he apparently haven't
read the fact that the house has
generally delegated all subpoena power
to the committee's that wasn't true at
the time in the Watkins case it wasn't
true 15 years to go over to this to now
second the house is a sole power of
impeachment and the manner of its
exercise may not be challenged from
outside whether we do it whether we
whether the
the president should be convicted upon
our accusation is a question for the
Senate but how we reached our accusation
is a matter solely for the house thirdly
we talked they talk about executive
privilege and they point to the Nixon
case that established executive
privilege that the president has a right
to private to candid advice and
therefore executive privilege is
established at the same case says that
executive privilege cannot be used to
hide wrongdoing and in fact President
Nixon was ordered in that case to turn
over all the material thirdly there's
the doctrine of waiver you cannot use
executive privilege or any other
privilege if you waive it the moment
President Trump said that John Bolton
was not telling the truth when he when
he said that the president told him of
the improper quid pro quo he waived any
executive privilege that might have
existed
he cannot characterize a conversation
and that and put it into the public
domain and then claim executive
privilege against it the president by
the way never claimed executive
privilege ever he has claimed instead
absolute immunity a ridiculous doctrine
that the president of the has absolute
immunity from any questioning by the
Congress of anybody else a claim
rejected by every court that has ever
considered it and finally the difference
from this president in any other
president claiming privilege of any sort
is that this president told us in
advance I will defy all subpoenas
whatever the nature I will make sure
that the Congress gets no information in
other words I am absolute the Congress
cannot question what I do because I will
defy all subpoena I will make sure they
get no information no matter what their
rights no matter what the situation that
is the subject of article two of the
impeachment because that is a claim of
absolute men article power thank you mr.
manager the majority leader is
recognized suggest after two more
questions on each side
one more I've been corrected as I
freaked when I am one more question on
each side we take a 15-minute break
thank you nice browser yes the senator
from Kansas I sent a question to - for
the council for president thank you
Senator Robert
would you please respond to the
arguments or assertions the house
managers made in response to the
previous questions direct you to the
counsel for the president mr. Chief
Justice members of the Senate I want to
respond to a couple first with regard to
the question or the issues that have
been raised as it relates to witnesses
it's important to note that in in the
Clinton impeachment proceeding the
witnesses that actually gave deposition
testimony were witnesses that had either
been interviewed by deposition in the
house proceedings grand jury proceedings
and that was specifically it was Sid
Blumenthal vert and Jordan Amman olinska
the retinue witnesses were not being
called that's because the house in their
process move forward with a full
investigation that did not happen here
there was another statement that was
raised by mr. chairman ship manager chef
regarding the Chief Justice could make
the determination on executive privilege
and again with no disrespect to the
Chief Justice the idea that the
presiding officer this proceeding could
determine a waiver or a applicability of
executive privilege would be quite a
step there's nothing historic precedent
there's no stark precedent that would
justify it but there's something else if
you get to the point of witnesses then
for instance if one of the witnesses to
be called were by the president's
lawyers was Adam Schiff in the role
basically of Kenton star Ken Starr
presented the report made the
presentation before the House of
Representatives had about 12 hours of
questioning I believe that's what Judge
Starr had if representative Schiff was
called as a witness would in fact then
issues of Speech and Debate Clause
privilege be litigated and decided by
the presiding officer
or would it go to court or maybe they
would waive it but those would be the
kind of issues that would be very very
significant senator Graham presented a
hypothetical which managership
said well that's not really the
hypothetical but hypotheticals actually
are that the hypotheticals I'll give you
to use atom about mentorships words he
talked about it would be wrong if the
FBI or the Department of Justice was
starting a political investigation of
someone's political opponent and I'm
thinking to myself but isn't that
exactly what happened the Department of
Justice and the FBI engaged in an
investigation of the candidate for
president of the United States when they
started their operation called crossfire
hurricane he said it would be targeting
a rival well that's what that did he
said it would be calling for foreign
assistance in that well in the
particular facts of crossfire hurricane
it has been well established now that in
fact fusion GPS utilized the services of
a former foreign intelligence officer
Christopher Steele to put together a
dossier and that Christopher Steele
relied on his network of resources
around the globe including in Russia and
other places to put together this
dossier which then James Comey said was
unverified insulation but yet it was the
basis upon which the Department of
Justice and the FBI obtained FISA
warrants and this was in 2016 against a
rival campaign so we don't have to do
hypotheticals that's precisely the
situation but to take it an additional
step this idea that a witness will be
called if the body decides to go to
witnesses that a witness will be called
would be a violation of fundamental
fairness of
course if witnesses are called by the
house managers through that motion well
the president's council would have the
opportunity to call witnesses as well
which we would Thank You mr. chief
justice
Thank You counsel Oh senator mr. Chief
Justice I sent a question to the desk
thank you
the question from Senator Harris is for
the house managers President Nixon said
quote when the president does it that
means that it is not illegal end quote
before he was elected president Trump
said quote when you're a star then let
you do it you can do anything
end quote after he was elected president
Trump said that article 2 of the
Constitution gives him quote the right
to do whatever he wants as president end
quote
these statements suggest that each of
them believed that the president is
above the law a belief reflected in the
improper actions that both presidents
took to affect their re-election
campaigns if the Senate fails to hold
the president accountable for misconduct
how would that undermine the integrity
of our system of justice
mr. chief justice
senators I think this is exactly the
fear I think if you look at the pattern
in this president's conduct and his
words what you see is a president who
identifies the state as being himself
when the president talks about people
that report is wrongdoing for example
when he describes a whistleblower as a
traitor or a spy the only way you can
conceive of someone who reports
wrongdoing as committing a crime against
the country is if you believe that you
are synonymous with the country that any
report of wrongdoing against the
president the person of the president is
a treasonous act it is the kind of
mentality that says under Article two I
can do whatever I want that I'm allowed
to fight all subpoenas now counsel has
given a variety of explanations for the
fighting of all subpoenas they might
have a plausible argument if the
administration had given hundreds of
documents but reserved some and made a
claim of privilege or the administration
has said will allow these witnesses to
testify but with these witnesses with
these particular questions we want to
assert a privileged but of course that's
not what was done here what we have
instead is a shifting series of
rationales and explanations and
duplicitous arguments some made in court
and some made here you have the argument
that the subpoenas aren't valid before
the House Resolution and then with
respect to subpoenas issued after the
House Resolution like two mabini
well those are no good either you have
the argument made that we have absolute
immunity and the court that addresses
this says no you don't you're not a king
that argument may be thought of with
favor by various presidents over history
it has never been supported by any court
in the land there's no constitutional
support for that either documents that
are being released right now as we sit
here and it's a mystery to the country
and it's a mystery to some of us
how our private litigants able to get
documents through the Freedom of
Information Act that the administration
has withheld from Congress if they were
operating in any good faith would that
be the case and of course the answer is
no what we have instead is we're gonna
claim absolute immunity even though the
court says that doesn't exist now they
said well we you know the the house
would through the subpoena and dr.
Kupperman why would they withdraw the
subpoena on dr. Kupperman when he was
only threatening to tie you up endlessly
in court now we suggested to counsel for
dr. Kupperman that if they had a
good-faith concern about testifying if
this was really good faith and it wasn't
just a stratagem to delay if it wasn't
just part of the president's wholesale
fight all subpoenas they didn't need to
file separate litigation because there
was actually a case already in court
involving Don Magan on that very subject
that was ripe for decision indeed the
decision would come out very shortly
thereafter and we said let's just agree
to be bound by what the McGann Court
decides well they didn't want to do that
and became obvious once the McGann Court
decision came out because the McGann
Court said there's no absolute immunity
you must testify and by the way if you
think people involved in national
security I eat doctor Kupperman and john
bolton if you're listening if you think
you're somehow absolutely immune you're
not so did doctor Kupperman said well
now I have the comfort I needed because
the court has weighed in the answer is
of course not now counsel says well we
might have gotten a quick judgment in
Kupperman yeah in the lower court do any
of you believe for a single minute they
wouldn't appeal the court of appeals and
to the Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court struck down the absolute immunity
argument they wouldn't be back in the
district court saying okay he's not
absolutely immune anymore but we're
gonna claim executive privilege over
specific conversations that go to the
president's wrongdoing okay that is the
sign of a president who believes he is
above the law that article 2 empowers
him to do anything he wants and I'll say
this if you accept that argument
if you accept the argument that the
president states can tell you to pound
sand when you try to investigate his
wrongdoing there will be no force behind
any Senate subpoena in the future
the fighting off subpoenas started
before the impeachment if you allow a
present to obstruct Congress so
completely in a way that Nixon could
never have contemplated nor would the
Congress of that day have allowed you
will eviscerate your own oversight
capability
thank you the mountains the majority
leader is recognized I suggest that we
resume at 4:00 o'clock without objection
so ordered